eu não sei o que é que se passa comigo
estou muito animado
o lado diz pessoal de quem fala em lutar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais um
faq bebeu e os estragos e que gente três
fármacos 763 e vamos lá que eu estou
animado e eu estou aqui me procurar a
cueca se ia embora pessoal desde já
deixam respirar um pouco e quando faz
vídeos parece que faz exercício físico
mas vá cair terceira noite à noite vamos
ouvir chamada desde já pessoal muito
obrigado pelos vossos dicas pela ajuda
que vocês me deram eu só sei que aquilo
animatronics chamas green trepp
um português de equipe e minha filha da
primavera é a franquia cinematográfica é
uma mistura de todos estes eletrônicos
tipo tudo juntos num obrigado também a
quem diz que aqui o cinema tronics vão
por cima ao longo do jogo tipo o banco
embora e e shishin até agora é só uma
por seu estilo - é isso é apenas
alucinações na minha cabeça é por isso
que eu não morro com deus me assustam
está isso deve ser tipo um trauma de
quando eu saí da pizzaria por que isso
agora é um parque de diversões
eu devo ter ficado com esse trauma
daqueles animatronics todos e é por isso
que eu tenho essa jogo se nações é que
mas basicamente a única coisa que mata é
que o animal tônicos brink trepp que
está a falhar agora no hotel jardim
lançou outra vez anda alguém a
ventilação eu tenho que gera ventilação
rápida lá anda lá esta terça feira à
noite supostamente a ser mais difícil
por isso têm que prestar mais atenção
agora também sair que o barulho do zé do
balão esprela deixe-me ver se consigo
ativar ok este barulho e viu agora
perdeu o meu eu não me deixa explicar
nada tá tranquilo
aí volta e faz até agora nenhum sinal
dos pré pago o que quer dizer que eu
estou é fazer as coisas bem como estava
explicou
o chinês é é um está na minha cabeça tem
calma
ok agora por um momento eu pensei que
tem mulher mas não é que é o dobro do
zero balão ser para atrair os brinquedos
para outros quartos vou tentar fazer
isso hoje
agora o vila chegou muita pressão já há
muita pressão na terceira noite porque
está tudo escuro luz por favor
ganhou bem
este barulho serve para atrair o z trim
preto para um quarto mais longe de
imaginar e me sinto um cara aqui o zé do
balão eu vai ser entre para que o quarto
porque pensa que eu vou estar ali
acho que é algo assim principalmente
estou confiar não com vocês disseram
pelo que eu li nos comentários no
twitter etc 31 basear nisso por isso se
vocês me enganaram acompanhamento também
é e pronto
e acho que não foi lá parar pois não é
que ela não é que a holanda está no foi
gay meu ok eu não encontre nenhum eu
estava entrando em convulsão após tom
neutro caiu 0 na outra vez
alô
deu na coluna que ela anda eu acho que
já mostrei né
aconteceu alguma coisa vamos ver as
câmeras imax inicial só que aí não está
sequer é previsível agora é um ou outro
alguma coisa falaram que era intenção da
capital
agora vou ver a inflação porque andava
na lei
eu vou triunfar é esta sala aqui ok
a câmera 8 está longe de mim
não não é um canal de áudio áudio é é
aqui e agora parece menos na janela ea
porta não sei o que está a acontecer mas
nesta terça feira à noite eu nem dá
pistas tipo 1 vai aparecer ela aparece
logo isso estamos o que é preocupante
porque eu só não dá assim pistas
concretas de onde está é e pronto e isso
acaba por buscar mas não é eu até agora
não viu de ficar mais conde dual sim
antes ela por si aqui com o braço fora
já não aparece aqui eu não andei aqui
nascida também não quer divulgar o áudio
que eu vim parar aqui e agora você não
aparece o caso porque ele é forte porque
eu já tive lá os pingos ao outro e
tentarmos estaríamos a taxa para cima e
até agora ainda não tinha aparecido
godoy
como é que os postos que para isto para
respirar assim meu duas das mais
inspiradas
assim a carga grande de eu sair deve ser
impresso da saúde o tac já também toquei
funciona se o cara que o áudio eo vem
pra saúde o toco áudio é isso mesmo até
agora vou fazer um teste e vou
experimentar tocar tipo na câmera ou não
nem acho que nunca uma parceira eu acho
que eu costumava por ser assim mas não
nesta não um que operou silva ac
aí eu sei o que farão os dois josé ao é
o rebu tal cinema tudo uma vez rápido de
plástico
eu pensei muito então é muito lenta
ipc-fipe meu mas o globo a esmola
escalar o dobro do tempo a fazer o que
não não não não tenho mais medo cuspiu
intrépido eu não me engano eu acho que é
esse que eu vou conseguir passar esse o
caraças não vai te embora por favor vai
te embora não sai da cabeça do boni o
corpo é do fred
eu não consigo identificar o resto está
a pintar e eu vou ficar eu vou mostrar o
filho da mãe sai daqui sai sai demônio
santanás vai ter que chegar a viagem de
alto padrão
ok vamos lá eu acho que tá escuro agora
eu não sei se eu tirar a visão aqui da
porta se ou vai aparecer ou não mas eu
acho que sim não ó que eu consegui ver
as câmeras agora aí o erro deve incluir
a ventar rápido para que o balão e agora
vem para esta sala e agora já consegue
ter mais não não eu tenho que respeitar
o meu como é que eu faço aqui meus não
têm portas não tem luzes não tem nada
stock car lutando para a próxima fase em
que uma porta
eu não tenho vários com este contato
visual de um boneco parece um cão
maltratado
ae não dá eu digo não dá é impossível
lembre se esta noite 3 está impossível
usar o que está aqui eu vou tentar
afastá lo mais um voto para que o áudio
ok vamos ver se eu passo preço alvo
passou exatamente funciona funciona até
agora vou triunfar aqui
cláudio de rock acho que exagerei a
exigir e já no áudio lá ok mas funciona
mesmo funciona mesmo usar o áudio para
afastá-lo da minha sala funciona até
estão três da manhã eu acho que foi o
máximo que conseguir avançar até agora
cai e eu não está aqui ok vou tentar
trio até que outra vez e ver se ela
parece já passou funciona mesmo quatro
da manhã pessoal também escravo é passar
um filme em quatro da manhã fui mas se
nós conseguimos chegar até agora nesta
noite eu saio dali só queremos
solucionar um cavalo cima são vocês que
vai perceber um boy eu sei eu não pensei
agora porque o que eu vou ficar aqui o
áudio aqui
vai parecer que né não apareceu
ai eu eu aqui temos mesmo quase mil são
cinco da manhã
eu vou tocar aqui o áudio através pela
parceira aqui e não saiu quando aparece
é porque deve estar dentro de ventilação
neste caso não está aqui agora é
possível que sim o que vamos ficar a
olhar um pouco o freio não vamos tocar
aqui é que agora tocar aqui e vai agora
precisa que o espetada vai por ser o
natal em natal eu fui um time nós atamos
dominará que o fight night at freddy's 3
rock enquanto instale a hora está a
passar-se um fim da manhã vai passar
para 3 agora né eu sei que só falta um
minuto eu passo isso sexta paguei manhã
à noite três completa conseguimos passar
esta noite 3 com muito custo e vamos
agora ninguém me locais última crônica
que encima sua tática e agora é vamos
porque não foi porque agora eu vou pelo
outro lado porque eu sei que o povo
baiano naquela sala eu venho porque
agora vamos ver funciona funciona cair
aqui tem umas mesas comprados com copos
tudo sabe eu tô com um toque na mão
contou com 11 campo kaká também por
pagar e meu não tolera tive um papo fred
e assim eu vou tentar ir por baixo de
seguir o pouga e por que não vou morrer
eu já sei como eu paguei meu está em
todo o lado a outra coisa pessoal é que
eu não são chinelos você já avisaram que
são honrados estão um pouquinho shinya
aoki não pressionavam rato - eles
quisessem que a causa por rosa para o
estado tenha calma assim na entrevista
vamos lá seguir por aí porque é
unicamente uma resto é tudo na sala
principal portal evento e eu não consigo
andar em frente à cozinha lá eu estava
um sítio muito estranho e tornar as
voltas pelo mesmo sítio zé manel para
encantar o que estava em pauta será o ok
esta sala é uma pessoal total que o
homem morto fred morto vamos lá vão
morrer até erro pronto já fui na bola e
errando mas contente para pagar e agora
é que falta pra matar
não sabemos mas esta noite quatro vai
ficar para o próximo episódio já sabem
deixa você por white favorito fiquem bem
até a próxima
[Música]
to